one of the things that I've learned  about public health is it's not about  medicine there are many of them are not  even biologically trained certainly not  clinically trained it's about Equity  that is the new Public Health Mantra and  if and that was not the right it's an  important prism I get it's important but  it's not the whole story and it was not  useful or not important in terms of  getting through this particular pandemic  what wasn't there somewhere there was  people in Texas denied antibodies  because they were the wrong color of  skin that have to Patient mind yeah  which is absolutely mind-boggling which  is absolutely crazy you take care of  someone depending on how much they need  to be taken care of not because of the  way that they were born with a  particular skin color and this happened  in the United States there's a viral  video of a guy filming as the nurse is  telling them you don't qualify he's why  not she's like oh you're white it's  absolutely mindful